meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
darf sie ganz herzlich hier im
bundeskanzleramt begrüßen nachdem die
letzten 24 stunden an dramatik kaum zu
überbieten waren möchte ich gern mit
ihnen meine einschätzung der situation
teilen
ich bin vor zwei jahren angetreten und
veränderungen in unserem land
durchzusetzen in einem land das
jahrelang durch stillstand der großen
koalition gelähmt war
ein land in dem die politische kultur
sehr stark von streit und ticker
dominiert war und ein land in dem das
system oftmals wichtiger war als die
bevölkerung
und am 15 oktober 2017 da haben die
menschen ganz bewusst veränderungen
gewählt sie haben sich dafür entschieden
und ich habe damals ein versprechen
abgegeben ich habe der bevölkerung den
wählerinnen und wählern versprochen dass
ich mir immer selbst treu bleiben werde
egal was kommt ich habe auch versprochen
dass ich wahrheiten aussprechen werde
selbst wenn diese unangenehm sind und
ich habe gesagt dass ich tun werde was
richtig ist und was notwendig ist
das war im moment stil und das wird auch
in zukunft so bleiben
ich war mir sehr wohl bewusst dass der
weg mit der fpö als regierungspartner
widerstand auslösen wird
aber man muss sagen dass zum damaligen
zeitpunkt die einzige partei die bereit
war eine koalition einzugehen die
freiheitliche partei war
wenn ich jetzt auf die letzten zwei
jahre inhaltliche arbeit zurückblicke
dann tue ich das aus voller überzeugung
und mit großer freude denn wir haben in
den letzten zwei jahren inhaltlich genau
das umgesetzt was wir auch im wahlkampf
versprochen haben
wir haben es geschafft die
schuldenpolitik in unserem land zu
beenden
wir haben es geschafft die steuerlast
für arbeitende menschen deutlich zu
senken und wir haben auch geschafft was
wir versprochen
nämlich die illegale migration nach
österreich massiv zu reduzieren
darüber hinaus ist es gelungen reformen
in der bildung einzuleiten die
sozialversicherungsträger
zusammenzulegen und im bereich der
digitalisierung sind wir mittlerweile
wieder an der spitze der europäischen
union
und ich möchte heute trotz aller
vorkommnisse ganz aufrichtig allen
regierungsmitgliedern für diese
umsetzung arbeit danken
und ich sage ganz bewusst ich danke
allen ganz gleich welcher partei sie
angehören
sie haben wahrscheinlich aber auch alle
mit verfolgt das in den letzten beiden
jahren für diese inhaltlichen erfolge
ich bereit sein musste viel auszuhalten
und auch vieles in kauf zu nehmen
vom raten gedicht über die nähe zu
rechtsradikalen gruppierungen bis hin zu
immer wiederkehrenden einzelfällen und
auch wenn ich mich nicht immer
öffentlich dazu geäußert habe so das
können sie sich wahrscheinlich
vorstellen gab es viele situationen in
denen mir das sehr schwer gefallen ist
das alles herunter zu schlucken
ich habe trotzdem im sinne der
sacharbeit nicht bei der erstbesten
verfehlung die koalition aufgekündigt
aber nach dem gestrigen video muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen genug ist genug
auch wenn die methoden klarerweise die
mich schon sehr eindeutig anteil
silberstein erinnern verachtenswert sind
der inhalt der ist einfach wie er ist
was über mich in diesem video gesagt
wird von beschimpfungen bis hin zu sehr
derben anschuldigungen und
unterstellungen
das ist alles eigentlich nebensächlich
was aber wirklich schwerwiegend und
problematisch ist das sind die ideen des
machtmissbrauchs die ideen zum umgang
mit österreichischen steuergeldern
natürlich auch das verständnis gegenüber
der medienlandschaft in unserem
die fpö schadet mit diesem verhalten dem
reformprojekt und dem weg der
veränderung
sie schadet auch dem ansehen unseres
landes
und es entspricht das möchte ich auch
ganz ehrlich sagen nicht dem politischen
zugang den ich habe nämlich der republik
und den menschen in unserem land zu
dienen vor allem und das ist aus meiner
sicht aber das schlimmste habe ich in
den heutigen gesprächen mit einigen
vertretern der freiheitlichen parteien
nicht den eindruck gewonnen dass ein
wirklicher wille da ist die
freiheitliche parteien abseits der
beiden rücktritte auf allen ebenen zu
verändern und ich glaube das wäre nach
den vorkommnissen der letzten tage mehr
als nur notwendig ich habe jetzt mehrere
möglichkeiten ich könnte natürlich es
mir leicht machen und versuchen nun
irgendwie die eigene macht aufrecht zu
erhalten ich könnte köpfe tauschen und
so tun als wäre nicht viel gewesen ich
könnte einen fliegenden wechsel zur
sozialdemokratie anstreben und damit in
kauf nehmen dass wir wieder genau
denselben stillstand haben den ich
zurecht jahre lang in österreich
kritisiert habe aber ich bin überzeugt
davon dass beides nicht das ist was
unser land braucht und auch ganz ehrlich
für mich persönlich wäre es nicht der
richtige weg denn ich bin in die politik
gegangen und ich lebe für die politik
nicht um ein amt inne zu haben sondern
um etwas daraus zu machen um auch für
unser land einen positiven beitrag zu
leisten
mein ziel ist ein ganz einfaches ich
möchte gerne für unser wunderschönes
land arbeiten und zwar mit meinem
politischen zugang mit meinem kurs und
auch mit der unterstützung der mehrheit
der bevölkerung aber ganz ohne
einzelfälle zwischenfälle und sonstige
skandale
ich glaube dass das derzeit mit
niemandem möglich ist
die fpö kann es nicht die
sozialdemokratie teilt meine
inhaltlichen zugängen
und die kleinen parteien sind zu klein
um wirklich unterstützung sein zu können
darum habe ich heute dem
bundespräsidenten vorgeschlagen
vorgezogene wahlen in österreich
durchzuführen und zwar zum
schnellstmöglichen zeitpunkt nur wenn
die volkspartei nur wenn wir nach der
wahl die möglichkeit haben auch wirklich
eindeutig den ton anzugeben
dann können wir die veränderung die wir
begonnen haben auch zu ende bringen und
fortsetzen und ich darf alle menschen in
österreich einladen die mit dem kurs den
wir die letzten jahre eingeleitet haben
die mit diesem kurs zufrieden sind dass
sie uns bei den wahlen unterstützen
ich glaube fest daran dass es in unserem
land wenn es regiert bar sein soll klare
verhältnisse und somit auch einen klaren
wählerauftrag für eine person geben
sollte die das land führen möchte darum
werde ich in den nächsten wochen und
monaten werben und dafür bitte ich
natürlich um ihre unterstützung
vielen dank